my name is Diane Wirth and I'm professor
of immunology and infectious disease at
the Harvard th Chan School of Public
Health I'm here today interviewing dr.
Kent Kester on his work in malaria ken
please introduce yourself I'm Ken Kester
I'm professor medicine uniformed
services University and head of
translational science and biomarkers at
sanofi pasteur can you tell me how you
first got involved to work on malaria
what were your first experiences it was
kind of an accidental thing I was an
infectious disease fellow in the early
1990s at Walter Reed Army Medical Center
and ended up working doing my research
rotation as an infectious disease fellow
with people who I knew in the Army who
ended up working on malaria one thing
led to another and research project
ended my fellowship ended I graduated
stayed on at Walter Reed and and ended
up doing malaria vaccine development and
more for probably the next 20 years in
the army
what do you think the biggest R&D
challenges are that we face today and
then maybe we've paid faced over the
last decade from my perspective it's one
of the biggest ones is funding we
recognize that that developing effective
interventions whether that's drugs or
vaccines against malaria requires
sustained funding and piecemeal funding
small grants and awards just don't do it
and if you're going to develop something
that's going to have a global
population-based impact it really has to
be done at an industrial scale so
funding is number one number two is is
sustaining interest on the part of the
scientific community there's no shortage
of research scientists who like to work
on malaria they have their their
favorite enzyme their antigens and it's
all good stuff but the challenge is is
that as sort of the the behemoth of
scientific funding and areas of emphasis
move along from innovative area to newer
innovative areas sometimes interest gets
lost and so it's important to maintain
that interest to grow next generation
of researchers and to keep keep the
pressure on to get things done you've
been in the military and now you're in
industry and you've been exposed to the
world health organization and
public-private partnerships can you give
us a sense of the roles of these
organizations how they differ and how
they've changed over the years
you know I think one of the big impacts
of sort of the worldwide malaria
research malaria R&D research
elimination eradication campaigns has
been this concept of public/private
partnerships it's clear that academic
groups well they have great ideas great
science a lot of enthusiastic motivated
young researchers don't necessarily have
the wherewithal to get products across
the finish line industry while can do
things at a big scale can get a lot of
things made and and deployed have the
regulatory throughput don't always
necessarily have that spark of
early-stage discovery interest so that
that's a disconnect government agencies
nonprofits I think they tend to fill in
the gaps and so it really is an
important concept this public-private
partnerships it's an it's an evolving
one I think where we are now as to where
we were say in the early 90s we're light
years ahead in thinking about the
development say of the RTSs vaccine
which you had familiarity with as you
were working in the military and and now
in your role at Sanofi looking at
vaccines more generally what made that
something to push forward as you say it
took a long time the RTSs vaccine was
decades in development and but now it is
an effective vaccine in humans I think
there was much work done with our CSS
and its predecessors for a number of
years that didn't really go anywhere a
lot of failed trials small studies 5 10
15 volunteers and it was really the
advent of combining RTSs the antigen
with novel adjuvant that had been
developed at that time by by SmithKline
Beecham now GlaxoSmithKline that really
showed for the first time that effective
actually could be achieved I think if
that hadn't happened the program
probably would have died that finding of
significant protection it really I don't
want to say it put the program on
steroids but it certainly propelled it
better and and made believers of people
who previously had thought that it
wasn't going to go anywhere as you think
to the future where do you see malaria
vaccine development going and where do
you see it kind of fitting into the
overall vaccine development the world
the vaccines has changed and and where
does malaria fit in this newer world
it's a great question you know if you
look at our TSS in many ways as you say
it's gone through really decades of work
to get where we are now it's kind of an
old-style vaccine that's not necessarily
a bad thing but if we were starting de
novo today we probably would do things a
lot differently
we have much different insights into
into malaria immunology protection
against disease in some ways analogous
to what's happened on a larger scale in
HIV so the whole you know fight against
HIV has just developed huge amounts of
knowledge about immunology and and I
think the RTSs work and and allied
efforts your other groups who want to
develop another vaccine or have
different antigenic idea building on the
work that the RTSs program has has has
done I think has really helped us a lot
we have a vaccine that that clearly
shows some degree of protection as you
say it has its advantages and it has its
limitations I think now we're at a point
where we can take a step back the field
and say okay how can we make this better
how can we leverage new technologies
whether it's genomics or other types of
omics things you know new ways of
interrogating the immune response and
really discerning correlates of
protection etc so I think it's really
been groundbreaking the only thing
that's been a bit discouraging of course
which goes back to my comment before
about funding it's taken a long time so
if you look in the industry you know if
you have an idea let's say for a
quote-unquote routine vaccine
whatever that means from from idea to
approval to deployment may take 15 to 20
years it may cost up to a billion
dollars for all the trials all the
production all that kind of stuff and if
you look at the amount of funding that's
gone to malaria vaccines well it's a lot
of money it's not a billion dollars yeah
it's it's a very interesting perspective
in thinking about vaccines in general I
mean there's this push now to get a Zika
vaccine and we hear that Zika vaccines
will be available really quickly so in
contrast to this long development period
what what makes that technologically
possible but also what makes that
possible and kind of been an advocacy
sense the big difference is of course is
malaria parasite so parasites have
evolved with us you know for millennia
and and so they know that they know how
to hide out they know how to how to live
with us in most cases there are multiple
antigenic variations of parasites so
that's part of it Zika it's one strain
it's a virus we know how to make viral
vaccines you know it's it's fairly
straightforward and I'm not saying that
that's necessarily a slam-dunk but it's
much easier than developing a vaccine
against the virus
there's already been a dengue vaccine
that that's been licensed a number of
countries around the world there's
yellow fever vaccine and there are other
vaccine candidates against other types
of flaviviruses that in experimental
settings actually work very well I think
that the concept of getting a Zika
vaccine technically made and and along
the approval pathway I think that's not
out of the question I think the bigger
challenge for Zika is how do you show
efficacy in a setting of perhaps an
unstable epidemic which we still don't
understand when eighty percent of the
people are actually asymptomatic so
there there's still some unknowns there
but I think from a technical standpoint
developing a Zika vaccine is is much
much easier so in some ways vaccine like
the yellow fever vaccine which was one
of the first successful vaccines led the
way in in some ways you can think about
RTSs maybe leading the way for malaria
vaccines in the same way because the
parasite is much more complex so I think
that
very interesting analogy to how to think
about where we are in malaria vaccine
development absolutely you show some
initial protection you show initial
value and if there's a need hopefully
the funders the advocacy groups and the
scientists who have the good ideas will
be able to run with it and I think
that's what we're seeing in terms of
eradication which is the kind of focus
of what we're talking about in general
do you think the vaccine is needs to be
there in order for eradication to be
successful you know if you if I think
about it you know eradication the
diseases that are eradicated or almost
eradicated in the world primarily are
through the use of a vaccine so do you
think it's possible to eradicate malaria
without a vaccine and I'd be interested
in your thoughts on that it's an
interesting question I you know as a
vaccine person and as a malaria vaccine
person of course I have to say yes yes
that it's important but but from a when
one takes a step back when we think
about controlling eradicating
eliminating malaria a lot of the
approaches are low-tech right get rid of
mosquitoes treat diagnose and treat
people get rid of standing water these
sorts of things
however again these are parasites
they're very wily parasites they're very
persistent if one is trying to develop
sort of a comprehensive approach to
eliminate malaria I think there's a role
for a vaccine just as much as there's a
role for mosquito control and bed nets
and and more what sort of advice would
you give someone who's kind of early in
their career or even pre career on on
what how to prepare themselves for a
leadership role as you've assumed in
your field I think part of it is is
don't just don't just limit oneself to
to excellence at the bench that's really
important you have to be scientifically
credible however if you really want to
make a difference you've got to
understand the issues you have to
understand how does a vaccine to fit
into a larger strategy you know how does
that fit into low-tech approaches and
public policy and whu-oh recommendations
etc etc from a realistic standpoint they
really need to be engaged just beyond
the bench you know understand the issues
make context and and really be involved
you know and it's not it's not
necessarily political advocacy it's it's
its scientific connectivity and under
and being engaged and being visible
that's a great way to think about it
having them reach out to others that
have complementary skills right you and
I have both dealt with many people in
our careers
who've shown an interest and we've
helped point them in those directions
and I think we can count a number of
those people who are now developing
leadership roles of their own right
which is a really good thing yeah well
thank you very much Kent this has been
fantastic great thanks